falta de personal equipamento el
servicio de urgencias de este hospital
de toulouse está saturado y al borde del
colapso
cada día hay más gente la gente que
podría ir a otro sitio tiene que venir
aquí porque no hay suficientes
instalaciones en la ciudad
el personal de urgencias está en huelga
desde el lunes por la noche sus
sindicatos ya advertía de una crisis en
2018 capital las condiciones de los
hospitales y las residencias de ancianos
han empeorado en los últimos 20 años
ahora es peligroso para los ciudadanos
eso el gobierno francés esperaba que una
prima mensual de 183 euros bastará para
aliviar las tensiones pero dos años
después el personal médico dice que hay
que hacer más mis sueños el personal
sanitario quiere un entorno de trabajo
seguro tanto para el paciente como para
ellos mismos
porque están cansados de trabajar en un
sistema roto
un país moderno como francia debería ser
capaz de cuidar la salud de los
ciudadanos
por su parte el gobierno insiste en que
está al tanto de la situación la semana
pasada al presidente emmanuel makoun
visitó un hospital en normandía donde
prometió llegar a la raíz del problema y
aportar soluciones